[Music]
[Applause]
we make way for the uh decorated espn
senior baseball insider jeff pasin who
joins us on the program if you have to
go
just say i gotta go and then you hang up
i know you're busy okay
uh you know what i i think that's a good
uh good way to approach it i'm not sure
that i'm gonna have to go but i
appreciate the app all right
juan soto the likelihood he will be
dealt before tuesday is what in your
opinion
[Music]
80 20.
and and i want to i want to focus first
on that 20.
that 20 depends on mike rizzo the
washington nationals general manager
if he continues to stick with the ask
that he has put out to teams up until
this point
i'm not sure juan soto is going anywhere
because he's been asking for
125 percent of juan soto's value he's
been asking for
five six players from teams and not just
five or six like guys no like five or
six tippy top prospects
from every organization he's been
talking to and so
if the ask remains at that then i'm not
sure juan soto is going anywhere for now
but
if he comes down a little bit i think
the san diego padres could jump i think
the los angeles dodgers could jump i
think the st louis cardinals could still
be in the mix though that depends on
their pursuit of starting pitching same
goes for the seattle mariners but the
padres and dodgers at this point seem
like
the likeliest landing spots for him and
if you look at what you have to give up
and then what you have to pay
i mean
that it's hard to check the box on both
of those to say we have what you want
and then we also have what he wants as
well
and
has the mike trout contract will it
affect these longer-term contracts do
you think uh as we move forward no
okay no not at all not going to scare
anybody i i don't
no i was having this discussion with
someone earlier this week who said to me
the mike trout contract is underwater
like my truck contract is
not under water at all i think if you
went
now granted we need to see how he comes
back from this back injury but every
indication
that i've gotten talking with people is
that the initial report from the trainer
was a little bit overblown trout himself
said that later on that day and that the
concerns of something long-term
really hampering him
are not particularly high but this is a
rotational sport dan and this is a back
injury and you have to rotate around
your spine for literally every important
thing that you do so back injuries in
baseball can be particularly difficult
for guys to come back from
we saw with don mattingly we saw it with
david wright i hope i hope to heavens
that we do not see the same with mike
trout because you know barry bonds
accepted it it's the most
uh amazing player i've seen in my nearly
two decades covering baseball now but
the notion that long-term big-money
contracts might be going no no
it's more dependent on the market
and the desire for these elite types of
players than it is on whether big
contracts in the past have succeeded or
failed you're going to have successes
you're going to have failures that
doesn't take away your desire to have
the best talent on your team
what's the market for shohei ohtani
everyone
i i mean let's let's put it this way if
if i told you dan
that you could go and get max scherzer
and matt olson
and it's the same person
what would you say to that nah hard pass
no of course you're gonna want him
what's the ability for teams to go get
him well that's dependent on two things
number one the talent level in your
organization i'd say probably half the
teams in baseball have the types of
players that the angels would want to
get back in any perspective shohei
ohtani deal but number two is the
appetite for actually going and moving a
true and that this word gets thrown
around no shohei ohtani is a true
generational talent and global idea
yes and and global and unlike anyone any
of us
watching listening alive have ever seen
i mean ohtani honestly ohtani is doing
things
even better
than babe ruth like
that's the crazy part of this whole
thing you know he came over here and it
was like well are we going to see no
we're going to see actually better than
babe ruth in terms of his ability to do
both at the same time okay but why would
the angels have him available or at
least be listening
they're listening because you should
listen on everyone to see if somebody
does such a
asinine godfather offer that you'd be
dumb to say no to it like they're
listening is a matter of course i think
they're they're listening
perhaps for information
a lot of the trade talks this time of
year you know you read i i don't do this
because i don't think talks are a
reportable thing because if you're not
talking with your cohorts then you stink
at your job but a lot of these talks are
nothing more than exploratory trying to
pick up on a queue somewhere where maybe
you get a sense that a team doesn't like
a player quite as much as you do and
then at the gm meetings of the winter
meetings a few months down the road you
can go back and say hey what about this
guy in a different type of deal so i i
think it's more informational at this
point and and hopeful perhaps that they
get an offer that they at least can take
to their owner but i don't think artie
moreno honestly right now has any desire
or intention to trade shohei ohtani the
the one guillotine that is hanging over
the entire proceeding is this the angels
don't look like they're necessarily
going to be very good next year dan and
chojeotani is a free agent after the
2023 season so if you weren't to move
him now
it would make a whole hell of a lot of
sense because the return is going to be
a lot greater for you know a year and a
half than it might be if you trade him
at the deadline next year
if you were shohei otani's agent are you
arguing negotiating for two players
salaries
yes yeah you're you're negotiating for
the
biggest average annual value salary in
baseball history so you're looking at 50
50 million dollars more yes yes that
that's and to me that's the floor
i mean
we listen listen dan we laughed damien
lillard i believe just signed a two-year
120-something million dollar extension
um i understand the nba is a different
game than major league baseball but
shohei otani's different player than the
other 1200
uh 29 in the rest of the league okay i
give you juan soto for five years shohei
otani for five years same price
oh
goodness
that's a good one
[Applause]
i'm probably going ohtani just because
the upside
for having dominant talent on both sides
of the game is there
but i i don't i don't under like i'm i'm
questioning myself instantaneously
because i don't know how i can pass up
on juan soto's ages 24 through 28
seasons like this is a guy who i believe
by the time it's all said and done is
going to be one of the 10 best hitters
in major league baseball history like
that that's how fond i am of juan soto's
offensive approach to the game and
uh all of his skills so
god that is quite the question dan
patrick and i i might actually
end up writing a story asking that same
question now because
i gotta i gotta think a lot more about
this that is that's one of those where
you get on the spot you're like oh that
host is just a terrible person for
asking that or you could say you know a
source asked me this question you don't
have to use my name
you can edit me out okay if you need to
uh thanks for joining us as always jeff
all right i'm gonna go check my phone
right now yeah
we're good okay that's jeff pass an espn
senior baseball insider